- C'est le chef de la diplomatie
ruenenenenenenenenenenenenenenex
et nos oreilles en Russie.
Depuis des mois,
les journalistes, caméramen et
recherchistes de Radio-Canada
témoignaient d'un climat de plÇe
d'un environnement de censure
qui est à son cblble.
- Depuis l'invasion russe,
l'étau s'était resserré.
En mars, Moscou avait adopté
de la presse, forçant CBC/Radio-
Canada à suspendre ses activités
en Ruse.e.
et cible le diffuseur public
canadien.
Après 44 ans de présence danso,
la fermeture du bureau de
CBC/Radinananada et révoque
les visas de ses journalistes.
durera tant que les chaînes
russes Russia Today seront
interdites au etetetetetetetetet
en mars.
Ce diplomate russe qualifiedidt
une propagande antirusse.
orororororororororororororororoe
d'un bureau de Radio-Canada.
LUCE JULIEN,trtrtrtrice générale
de l'information de Radio-Canada
- Radio-Canada/CBC est
une entreprise de presse
du gouvernement canadien.
On a démontré ça depuis
rsrsrsrs et nous le sommes
encore, alors c'est extrêmement,
effectivement, choquant.
- Le public canadien est
le plus grand perdant,
adadadadadadadadadadadadadadada.
TAMARA ALTÉRESCO, correspondante
de Radio-Canada en R
- Ça ne se remplace pas
la présence sur le terrain.
On était pas des envoyéscocococ.
On s'imprégnait de la culture,
et on le t t t tout, carrément.
- Cette décision survient
après des années de relations
diplomatiques de plus en p
Le premier ministre canadien
n'est pas étonné.STSTSTSTSTIN T,
premier ministre du Canada
que c'est une menace
pour Poutine qui dépend l l l l,
de la mésinformation pour
d'induire ses citoyens enururure
justifier cette guerre illégale.
- La décision de retirerlelelely
au Canada a été prise
de manière indépendante, assure
le gouvernem
PABLO RODRIGUEZ,
ministre du Patrimoine canad
- C'est le CRTC qui a consulté
une tonne de Canadiens, a
rendu une décision de presque
l l l l l l l l l l l l l l l e
qui dit : "Oups, on met tous
les journalistes deh
- Malgré ces représailles,
la ministre des Affaires
étrangères ne reviendraitNININIe
des Affaires étrangères
- C'était enenenenenente
décision de bannir un agent
de propagande du gouvernement
russe qui est RT.
permettraient-ils de renverser
la décision de Moscou?
trtrtrtrtrtre n'est pas
très optimiste.
- La relation, ell
russe.
- les organismes de défense de
la liberté de la presse sont
inquiets.ivivivivivivivivivivivx
et c'est important justement de
rappeler à la u'u'u'u'u'u'u'une
démocratie ça permet aux
journalistes de pouvoir faire
leur travail même quand ça fait
- Le sort des employés locaux
de Radioususususususussie
demeure incertain. D'ici là,
Radio-Canada continuera
de couvrir la Russie à dis
dans cette région du monde.
retourner en Russie, mais pour
faire mes bagages et vider
le bureau. Ça, c'est le statu
quo. En ce moment, on peut
espérer qu'on va prendre ça au
jour
de la presse accuse un autre
recul en Russie et
ces représaill
familière à laquelle le public
canadien s'était attaché.
- Ici Tamara Altéresco,
Radio-Canada
... à Sambek, près
de la frontière